Bố cũng không thông thống như kiên emu trên thống bà cho biết, các hệ thống phòng thu của tổ chức hiếp ước
hóc đại thế dừng là tổ đại đánh chặt một tên lợi đã đảo phòng tự ưu răng,
sau khi tên lợi này, bây giờ có phần nước này, theo tên bố của anh gara,
tên lợi đã bị vô hiệu hóa bởi các hệ thống phòng thu tên lợi của nát頭 trên khai
tạc của bực liệt trung hại.
Một số mạnh bởi giới xuống cú đất trọng mơ tình gà dàng tếp, lâm ngâm thu như kiên,
sông phòng về trường bão hay tế thải.
Đây là bụt đánh chẳng thứ 2 sau một sự việc tương tự và ngay trước,
hồi một bố thống 3, nát頭 của bàn hả một tên lợi đã đảo khác được phòng tự ưu răng hướng về thu như kiên.
Sau sự việc, lý mình này cho biết đã tăng cường trong tháng tháng tháng thu tên lợi đã đảo trong khu bực.
Tổng thống thu như kiên, Rên xíp, tế yếu, e Đồ Wang cho biết,
anh gara đã gửi thống bảo tế, tế hư răng sau sự việc.
Đông thời khẳng để gương lại thực hiện mọi biển phóc cần thiết, một cách kiên quyết,
trước các một đezu at nhận vào lạnh thổ và công phát.
Về Iran chưa bị giòn về vụ việc mọi nhất, nhưng trước đó sau vụ đánh chạm đầu tiên,
tế răng phủ nhận đã phòng tên lợi về phía thu như kiên và khẳng định,
tốn trong trục quyền của nước này.
Các thẳng đã chung đông ra tăng sau khi Mỹ và Instagram trên hành cho cuộc công tiết nhỏ bị Iran từng hành cao tháng 2.
Déo theo các đột tình công trả đủ ở bòng tên lợi và thích bị bài thương những lái của tế hay răng và khu bực.